sometimes our president has been  criticized for what we what is seen as  divisive rhetoric in this country how do  you think it's viewed on the  international stage look increasingly I  think and I'd make this statement about  any of us you know even if you're from a  smaller country like New Zealand you you  you can be shot on to a platform  depending on on what's happening in your  corner of the world the point I've tried  to make is that increasingly we're  actually all amplified within each  other's borders so nothing that we say  within our own countries anymore is just  limited to that we will hear each other  now and our peoples feel the effect of  that and I don't say that to point to  any one leader actually that's a duty of  care that we all have and in this  borderless worlds now I think we need to  be mindful that other countries here  kids hear it and and I would say have  impact